[Music]
all right let's go to
blake in amarillo tejas
como estas blake how are we doing hey dr
john how's it going
i'm all right brother how are you
you know what you wouldn't be calling me
so what's
what's happening man well uh the gist of
it
is uh my mom's
my mom lives with me my fiance and my
baby
um and she's
she's locked in this fantasy of people
are after her
that she has been sex trafficked but
she's actually in the process of being
sex trafficked
um right now
um she's been in this loop for
seven years now or so she says it goes
all the way back to 1993.
uh it's like the date keeps changing and
going further and further back
um have you ever taken her to the doctor
i've i've walked her into the pavilion
here in town and she walked right out
and she's smart she went to school for
psychology she her
pretty much as far as i can remember she
has read
books on mental illnesses
she's she knows what to tell
counselors and psychologists she'll
she'll tell her story and it'll sound a
little nutty but she'll keep out a lot
of details
okay uh she'll keep out details as far
as the way she gets her information
is from her facebook feed okay
she uh scrolls through it and the random
stuff that goes up there are signs to
her
it's her being uh reading in between the
lines
okay so um dr phil
yeah dr phil will tell you all kind of
things right just kidding i like doctor
well
doctor i've never really you're you're
the only uh
psychologist that i've ever actually
truly listened to
you know over podcasts and stuff and i'm
not i'm not even a psychologist that's
even
that's even better man you're making me
feel good about myself blake
hey so um how long has this gone on with
her has this been something you've dealt
with since she was
since you were a kid or is this
relatively new no i don't think so
um how old is she i don't she's 54
okay and she's been doing this
she's lived with me for about two years
and it's been pretty much quiet
up until a couple days ago she left my
sister's house calling it a sex
trafficking house
putting notes on people's cars um
and that dr phil and his people told her
that it's a sex trafficking house and
all these people that are after her
um and oprah winfrey is
in it somehow too uh even as we sit here
and talk she is sitting on my patio
talking to herself on facebook and
answering herself
on commenting on a post that she made
there's oh there's like 50 comments on
there of just her talking to herself and
talking to these people
and asking questions and then giving
legitimate answers
like you should ask a question and then
they would come out
they would they don't say anything and
then she pulls
up on the answer that i don't know what
the answer was but
and only me and my brothers and sisters
and my fiance and
my aunt shirley now can see it because
we're
her friends but so here's what i want
you to do
um one of a couple of things is going on
here
number one she has um had or is having
but it sounds like has had a
psychotic break and she needs to get
some help asap
okay um if you stay on the line here
which is down the line and i've
got some people in your area that i
trust in fact i
was on the phone with them um on another
call
getting some wisdom and guidance um
earlier today
and so i'll give you their contact info
and that's who i'm gonna recommend you
reach out to and they'll guide you
through the resources there
in amarillo okay um
you've got two things happening here
number one you've you've got your mom
who you love
do you have custody of her anyway or she
just crashing with you guys
no she's just with us okay uh
so no it's papers how is this impacting
your fiance and your little baby well
um megan sorry
my fiance talked about
she she brought it up to me that if she
ends up leaving it's not leaving me
yeah it's leaving for her safety
and as soon as the situation's cleared
up she would come back and i get that
and my son's safety my mom's not violent
she never has been i've never
seen her be violent but i understand
where she's coming from on that
and you've also never seen this right
i not like this okay
so i think your fiance is wise
um and i applaud her for having the
courage to tell you that
and so i would look at that as a signal
and
at some point you're gonna have to make
a choice between
mom and fiance baby
not bart i i know and that's exactly
what i told her
and i already told my mom because i had
a conversation with her because she
busted into my bedroom
but not busted in this little dramatic
she knocked on the door and i told her
to come in
yeah kind of thing and she accused megan
of talking to one of these people
okay that are sex trafficking her and i
had a conversation with her saying mom
you can't do that yep that cannot happen
this is her home
and that's i told her that when it comes
to my son
when it comes to megan understand that
they come first
and kind of telling her without telling
her
okay now you need to tell her with
telling her
this is the time to be very very clear
my boss dave says all the time clear is
kind
and so i would write down on a piece of
paper probably type it up
and if your brothers and sisters are
there too that y'all all call a family
meeting
asap and type up the following
you are not in a being sex trafficked in
a sex
ring that is coming from my sister's
house period okay
um and make sure that all the facts are
written there
say if you were to continue to stay in
this house you will go get the
psychiatric care that you need
period and if you choose not to go
get the psychiatric care that you need
then you are choosing to go live
somewhere
else and that's going to be a hard
conversation that's going to be a
conversation full of tears probably
yelling
and whatever but you've got to draw a
boundary on behalf of your family
of your fiance and especially your child
yeah and in a perfect world she goes and
gets the help she needs
i'm not going to make diagnosis over the
radio but my hunch
these are very very difficult situations
okay
well i told her this last
tuesday i had to call out crisis
prevention
because she told me that she would have
to kill herself for me to understand
and from listening to you on spotify i
dropped the conversation called the
people that could handle it good for you
because i
i can't but uh they came in and she
willingly went back to the pavilion
and they couldn't hold her because she
didn't give a plan or an action
statement to it
and listen as an adult if
she does not make a threat on her life
in the state of texas they probably
won't be able to hold her
yeah right feeling you're trapped in a
simulation or in some sort of matrix
doesn't make you dangerous and that
doesn't mean they're going to take you
this is going to be something that she's
going to have to decide to do on behalf
of you your family
and that makes these incredibly
difficult
so what i want you to know is doing the
right thing here is not going to be the
easy thing it's not going to be the
gentle thing it's going to be loud and
heartbreaking and all those things that
doesn't mean it's the wrong thing
i'm also not recommending you throw your
mom out on the street if y'all are all
pitching in on this i think you get your
brothers and sisters together
you'll talk about money you'll talk
about finances all that kind of stuff
that y'all gonna need to do here to
rally around mom
but your fiance is right because this
feels like it's escalating it feels like
it's moving in a direction
and whenever i'm working through these
situations i'm always looking for the
directionality
has this been way mom has been since she
was little this is just who she is
or is this thing moving at a at an
increasingly
faster speed towards a negative outcome
and i don't like the trajectory of what
you're
the way you're telling me that this has
come on and it's gotten more now she's
getting a little more bold and then she
told sister and now she's
threatening to hurt herself i just don't
like the trajectory of this thing you
got to get the professionals in
and the professionals aren't going to
take her if she's not going to make a
direct
um she's not directly a harm to self for
others
so get with your brothers and sisters
make a plan have the hard hard
conversation
before you do all that get away with
your
fiance and your little baby and look
your fiance in the eye and say i'm 100
on your side
and i'm 100 on your team and i'm gonna
do what's right here in this situation
it's gonna be hard and challenging and
i'm gonna need your support because i'm
gonna have i may have to kick my mom out
of my own house
it's gonna be really hard for everybody
um i may have to we may have to budget
for mom's care because we're gonna all
pitch in
um but it's gonna be hard i'm gonna need
your help but
i never want you to ever question who
comes first in this house
it's a little baby and it's you so i
mean it's
hard hard hard brother blake i'm sorry
um thank you so much for call let me
know how that conversation goes
let me know how it ends up and we will
circle back and i want to let everybody
know
we can get an update on your mom